(whoosh, click and beep)
- Dr. Joseph Sullivan has spoken
at our conference before,
although it's been too long,
so welcome back.
Dr. Sullivan is the director of the
UCSF Pediatric Epilepsy Center
and associate professor of neurology
and of pediatrics.
Good morning.
- Morning.
Thank you for having me.
I was thrilled to be able to come back
because there actually have been a lot of,
I think it was four years
ago, there's actually
been a lot of developments in the
pediatric epilepsy space.
A lot of that has focused on genetics.
You'd have to probably be living in a hole
to have not heard about medical marijuana
and its implications (laughs).
I have a few slides about some of the data
at the end of this talk.
When I was first asked to come back,
I was asked to speak
about atypical seizures.
I think that's kind of a broad term.
I think a lot of caregivers
and medical providers,
when they think about seizures,
maybe the first type of seizure that jumps
to their mind is a grand mal seizure
or a generalized tonic-clonic seizure.
I often, when we're
teaching our residents,
try to tell them that that is actually
only one of many different seizure types.
It shouldn't be an alliteration word.
When we get the call from the ER,
well, what type of seizure was it?
Generally, a tonic-clonic seizure.
I think that with detailed
video EEG monitoring
and being able to take
care of a whole host
of different patients really allows us
to phenotype, so describe
the different types
of seizures that we can see across
different patient populations,
and certainly in children
and in young adults
with developmental disabilities.
We do know that these different
seizure types can occur.
With that,
here is the overview.
I just wanna do a very cursory overview
of the incidence of epilepsy in children.
I then wanna just talk about, I could do
a one-hour talk on each of these single
seizure types, but sort of hit on a couple
of the common syndromes that we see
in children and young adults with
developmental disability.
I wanna talk a little bit about the impact
of genetics and the era
of whole exome sequencing.
I certainly was one of those that said,
"Oh, yeah, genetic testing is interesting,
"but right now it doesn't
actually translate
"into any changes in our management,"
but that is changing, and it's likely
gonna be, continue to change in the next
five to 10 years.
Then I'll talk about some of the
emerging treatment options.
These are my disclosures.
I am involved with a couple
of pharmaceutical companies
that are actually investigating
some of these novel compounds for some
of the rare genetic epilepsies.
Just some simple definitions.
What is a seizure?
There are actually
three-hour-long symposia
at the American Epilepsy Society meeting
about what is a seizure.
This is still debated,
but for our purposes,
I think we can come to an agreement
that it's a transient occurrence of signs
and/or symptoms due to
an abnormal, excessive
or synchronous neuronal
activity in the brain.
This is what we spend
all of our time doing,
looking at EEGs and videos to see
what's the first thing that happened.
Did the right arm move?
Did the left arm move?
Did the head turn to the side?
'Cause that allows us to look back
at our neuroanatomy and have some type
of hypothesis as where that seizure
is actually starting.
As opposed to epilepsy.
Again, this is debated and the definitions
are changing, is still simply defined
as two or more unprovoked seizures
greater than 24 hours apart.
People debate this because what happens
when someone has a seizure, and then
five years later has their second seizure?
Does that patient have epilepsy?
Chief Justice John
Roberts, he has epilepsy
'cause that's actually happened to him.
I would say yes.
Most of the patients that I treat,
it doesn't become that nuanced because
the kids are often
having frequent seizures.
Then this is an expansion
of the definition.
Having one unprovoked seizure.
The probability of having a second seizure
being equivalent to if you already had
a second seizure, which is
generally around the 60%.
There's a trend towards
actually giving someone
a diagnosis of epilepsy at that point.
Now, we can debate
whether or not we should
actually intervene and start treating
in that scenario of someone
who has a single seizure,
has a high increased
risk of a second seizure.
Do we actually treat?
My personal practice is that I don't
because we still don't know when
that second seizure may be.
The example that I just brought up,
it may be five years.
In that scenario, you've exposed someone
to a medication for five
years unnecessarily.
If it happens within the next few months,
then I think it's
actually pretty clear that
that tempo of having a
seizure every few months
warrants intervention.
Then diagnosis of an epilepsy syndrome.
What is an epilepsy syndrome?
This is the other academic topic
that we get really excited about.
If we can take someone that walks into
our clinic with a diagnosis of spells,
and then have them leave with a diagnosis
of an epilepsy syndrome
so that they actually
have a more specific label that they
can put on their diagnosis,
not only does that actually help inform
treatment and prognosis,
but as I'll show you
in a couple of slides,
I think it really helps
families reach out to other
disease-specific organizations so that
they know that
they can have support from other people
who are dealing with
similar types of seizures
and comorbidities.
What is an epilepsy syndrome?
It's a complex of signs and symptoms
that define a unique epilepsy condition
with different etiologies.
The three pillars that go into determining
the epilepsy syndrome
are the age of onset,
so very different if someone presents
at six months of age as
opposed to six years of age,
the seizure type and then the EEG pattern.
Again, this is what we do in comprehensive
epilepsy centers, is
rather than just giving
someone the diagnosis of seizure disorder,
which I hate that term, seizure disorder.
It tells us nothing.
People who have,
don't have heart rhythm disorders, right?
They have specific cardiac arrhythmias.
We like to be able to be very accurate
in our seizure diagnosis.
Lastly, this term, semiology.
I'm gonna show you a
few seizure videos here.
The semiology are all of the nuances
that happen prior, the onset, during
and after the seizure that allow us
to put a label, other than
generalized tonic-clonic.
How about epilepsy in children
with intellectual disability?
This is an old paper,
but epilepsy's common.
Even in the general
population, it's estimated
to be about 1% of the population.
But it has a five-fold increase
in prevalence in those with
intellectual disability.
When you look at the severity
on intellectual disability, you can see
there's a range here, but if one has mild
through the spectrum of
severe, the incidence
of epilepsy does increase as the severity
of the intellectual
disability also increases.
Why?
Why is that?
Well, I don't think we actually know.
I think the genetics here are, hopefully,
gonna shed a little
bit more light on that.
But when I explain this to parents,
I basically say epilepsy
simply is a disorder
of brain function.
Development and cognition in a child,
in a developing brain, rely
on normal brain function.
Because development is
not a static process,
you can imagine that someone who is prone
to having seizures as a result of a
functional disorder of
their brain may also
be prone to having abnormal
development over time.
This is one of the joys and frustrations
of my job.
Yes, adults, your brain is still changing,
but hopefully we would
all agree, when we have
a newborn that then becomes an infant
and then a sassy teenager, a lotta stuff
happens there in the brain.
It is a moving target.
We can have instances where there's either
a genetic abnormality, a structural
brain abnormality, that is present
in the newborn, period, but may actually
not be symptomatic until later on.
We have to be prepared
to re-evaluate children
as they mature because their seizure types
may change.
That may actually dictate a
change in their treatment.
Just a little vignette here.
You have a child who comes in with
new onset infantile spasms.
I'm gonna show you a video of this.
We do brain MRI, which is pretty much
standard of care now.
It shows a developmental
brain malformation.
That patient is treated and does well.
Spasms respond, and this
child is seizure free
for a few years.
But then later, that child develops
a new type of seizure,
tonic and atonic seizures,
which, again, I'm gonna show you.
Now this is a diagnosis of
Lennox-Gastaut syndrome.
Then we treat Lennox-Gastaut syndrome
with very different types of medications.
It's unusual to be able to get someone
with Lennox-Gastaut
syndrome truly seizure free,
but then as that child becomes an adult
and ends up in my adult
epilepsy colleague's clinic,
then they actually may just look like
they have treatment-resistant
complex partial seizures.
I think my adult epilepsy colleagues
have a really difficult job because
these patients show up.
Unless you go back or they've come
from their pediatric
colleagues and you have
the nice longitudinal documentation
of all the different
seizure types, you may not
appropriately diagnose
someone in adulthood
unless you go back and understand how
their seizures presented
and how it evolved
over time.
Onto a few videos here.
Infantile spasms.
Here's a cute little baby.
Let's just play this
video for those of you
who haven't seen.
What you'll see, awake,
alert, interactive,
non-dysmorphic-appearing
baby who is starting
to have what we would say are bilateral
flexor-extensor.
You see the hips are coming up,
the legs are coming up.
The arms are extending, and then briefly
adducting to the midline.
It's coming in a cluster.
It's coming pretty regular.
Very often there's a cry in between there.
This is actually taken from the
Child Neurology Foundation website about,
it's an instructional video.
It couldn't be any more classic.
You see the little
facial grimace, as well.
This is something that we drive home
to our pediatric residents, that if you
have a baby who's having
startles or having
these exaggerated Moro response,
the Moro reflex, that if
it's coming in clusters
like this, that's
something that, arguably,
is one of the infantile
epilepsy medical emergencies,
in the sense that you want these kids
evaluated likely within a week.
That's a very typical
video for infantile spasms.
I'm just gonna go through
this sort of table here
for a couple of the syndromes so that
we understand why making that specific
seizure diagnosis and semiology diagnosis
is important.
You can see the age of
onset is in infancy,
hence the name infantile spasms.
The seizure semiology,
that was pretty classic
of the flexor-extensor spasms.
We have the mix.
You don't always have
to have the flexor part.
You don't always have to
have the extensor part.
You can have just each of those.
But once you see it, it's really hard
to misdiagnose.
I think the thing that
happens with families
they get really nervous
about is they worry
about the duration of the seizure.
The cluster may last 15, 20 minutes,
but you saw each one of
those individual spasms
literally lasted for about one second.
If you have 20 to 30 spasms
in a 20-minute cluster,
that total time spent seizing was actually
only 20 to 30 seconds.
The EEG is very helpful.
It can show us this classical
hypsarrhythmia pattern.
It really can be made in
a one-hour outpatient EEG.
It's very important to capture sleep.
This is another teaching point.
We tell our medical residents that if you
have a baby that did that in your office,
and the EEG is normal,
you have to make sure
that you've actually captured sleep.
You can't just write them off.
If you did capture
sleep, you have to repeat
that EEG in a few weeks because it could
be a chance that you're
actually just making
this diagnosis very, very early,
and the hypsarrhythmia hasn't
had a chance to develop.
The etiology is really, really broad.
Malformations of cortical development
or neonatal encephalopathy, so some
perinatal birth difficulties,
represent the majority,
but the very, very close second in the era
of genetic testing are
various genetic abnormalities.
You can see here Tuberous sclerosis,
neurofibromatosis and
Down syndrome are some
of the common genetic diagnoses.
I'm gonna show you a slide later
with a whole host of genes that have now
been associated with infantile spasms.
Treatment is very different.
These aren't the kids that
we give phenobarbital.
These aren't the kids that we give Keppra.
These are very
syndrome-specific treatments.
Generally high-dose steroids, which is not
a great medication, in
terms of tolerability,
or a medication called vigabatrin,
which does have some potential
for retinal toxicity,
but when we look at the
developmental outcomes
of untreated infantile spasms, we know
that being aggressive early in trying
to cycle through the
treatments that we know
can be effective is critical to having
any chance of a normal
developmental outcome.
Moving onto one other syndrome
here, so Lennox-Gastaut.
I have a series of three videos here.
Here's a young woman with Down syndrome
who came in to better
understand what types
of seizures she's having.
You can see she's playing with her little
Etch A Sketch thingy.
Oh, here we go.
She has abrupt jerk there.
Extension of the arms.
Then she looks like it's done.
Then it happens again.
She's holding it.
Then she just readjusts herself,
and then she's gonna totally pick up
her little toy here again
and start playing with it.
You can see that there's some overlap
between a spasm.
That actually had a
little bit of a stuttering
and clustering, but that was it.
That was just two.
But you can see that the
duration that the arms
were held was longer.
It was not this sort of crescendo,
decrescendo of a spasm.
Rather, this is a tonic seizure.
Sometimes it's not so easy.
Here you're gonna see a combination
of two things.
The helmet should be a giveaway
that this child is at risk for falling.
Mom's holding onto his hand here.
That actually went a little bit slower
than it was supposed to, but you can see.
Imagine what would have happened if he
would not have been
standing at the bedside
and Mom would not have had her hand there.
He would have dropped to the ground.
There is a common theme now,
especially in epilepsy drug studies,
of how you count these seizures.
What do you call that?
You notice the arms went
out, the head went down.
We can have epilepsy banter here.
Was that a tonic, atonic?
Was it tonic with a head drop?
All these different things are interesting
and can be teased out with
detailed video EEG monitoring,
but the big picture, the drop attack.
This kid would have fallen.
We treat drop attacks very seriously
because of the secondary injuries that
these patients can sustain.
Then on that same theme,
here's another child
who's playing with his truck.
You're gonna see, he's actually
in a sitting position.
If he was just to have atonia, he may fall
to the side, which he
kinda does, but the arms
come out, and then there's still that
little bit of extension.
He stays extended.
Dad's over there in the corner.
He's like, I think you're okay.
(laughter)
He stays down, and then he sits back up.
Those are all sort of themes of tonic
and atonic seizures that
lead to drop attacks.
We just know that drop
attacks carry a very,
they're brief, but
because of the associated
morbidity that they cause, with regard
to secondary injury, they
can be very debilitating
for patients and their caregivers.
What is Lennox-Gastaut syndrome?
I have a European-Italian colleague.
The Europeans are very good semiologists.
They really scrutinize even better than
the Americans do.
There's a lotta debate as to us Americans
over diagnosing Lennox-Gastaut syndrome.
That may be true 'cause the core syndrome,
as described by Lennox and Gastaut,
probably is rare, but for the purposes
of our talk here, I just
want to sort of lump them
into these types of
seizures that we can see,
namely the tonic axial seizures,
which you saw the picture of,
and then the atonic seizures.
The other key component
that really represents
that core phenotype are these atypical
absence seizures, which these are the ones
that are very, very difficult to tell.
Even when you have neurotypical kids,
they're gonna stare.
Adults stare.
I can see some of you
guys staring right now.
Are you actually having (laughter)
an atypical absence seizure?
It's very difficult to tell.
In some children and young adults
with intellectual disability,
parents, they know these kids well,
just like we said in the previous talk.
They are their best provider.
They can tell that something happens
and that there's an on and an off.
But sometimes the on of the staring
or the sort of little bit of being
a little bit more disconnected
is a little bit more gray, and the off
is a little bit more gray.
I would argue that it's almost impossible
to be 100% sure unless you actually have
a EEG on at the time.
That is the seizure type that tends
to really bring all those three, tonic,
atonic and the atypical absence together
to represent the true core phenotype
of Lennox-Gastaut syndrome.
The EEG findings, it's very, very helpful.
We can actually see EEG abnormalities
even in between seizures.
With an appropriate history of those types
of seizures that you would describe to me,
together with a one-hour EEG, we can
very often make the clinical diagnosis
of Lennox-Gastaut.
You'll see some overlap here, in terms
of the etiologies of infantile spasms
in Lennox-Gastaut.
Brain malformations, so malformations
of cortical development are very common.
You can see that there
can be this evolution
from infantile spasms to Lennox-Gastaut.
This is also associated
with Down syndrome,
associated with Angelman syndrome.
From the few autopsy
specimens that we do have,
there can be, the patients that actually
have normal brain MRIs are thought
to maybe have microscopic
neurodevelopmental abnormalities
or sort of cortical
dysplasia, where the normal
six-layer cortex is not
organized in the way
that it should.
But still, there's a
whole host of patients
that, to this day, are Lennox-Gastaut
of unknown cause.
That's really where we hope
that with whole exome sequencing
we're gonna arrive at some discoveries.
Treatment.
We base it on seizure type, but we also
base it on experience in the literature
over the last four
decades, since valproate
has been available.
We know that valproate and valproate
and lamotrigine together can be very,
can be actually synergistic.
Benzodiazepines, I know we don't like
benzodiazepines, but
they can be very helpful
for the different
seizure types that we see
in this syndrome.
Then the medication felbamate.
It's not a medicine that we usually
reach for as the first
or second-line medication
in any of the epilepsies, but it can
be particularly effective for the tonic
and atonic seizures that are associated
with this syndrome.
Because of the morbidity that they cause,
I tend to start having
that talk with families
sooner rather than later.
The incidence of intellectual disability,
sorry, I have this old term in there,
my apologies, is high.
We know that the chronic
treatment-resistant seizures
can evolve over time.
Again, you have to be able to react
accordingly to those
different seizure types.
Here's my really simplified breakdown
of what I do in the clinic every day.
You have someone who
comes in with seizures
and a developmental disability.
We still, all this fancy
EEG, whole exome sequence,
we still wanna look at the patient,
talk to the family and examine them.
I am not a geneticist.
I am not a dysmorphologist.
If I see something that
look a little different,
I will rely on my genetic colleagues
to hopefully refine that bit.
But if someone does have specific features
of a genetic syndrome, we wanna proceed
to targeted gene testing.
Then if we have a specific diagnosis,
such as Down syndrome,
such as Angelman syndrome,
we can then still, it's clinically based.
We're still going to treat based on
the predominant seizure
type, but this is where
we can use the literature
and we can use family reporting.
Now the whole explosion of social media,
often families are coming into me and say,
"Well, I read on the
Angelman syndrome board
"that that is a bad medicine
for Angelman syndrome."
We're learning a lot
as healthcare providers
from families.
If you have someone who
just has non-specific
or pretty much a normal neurologic
and physical exam, then we
have to sort of broaden,
I think, our net a bit.
We still rely very, very
heavily on neuroimagings,
brain MRI.
Even in the age of genetic
panels and exome sequencing,
we can't forget about a good old
chromosomal microarray 'cause we can still
pick up different copy numer of variants
on a microarray that can
be very, very important
in 10 to 15% of patients with seizures
and developmental disability.
Then really, with the
imaging and some type
of genetic testing, we can go into two
broad branching points,
where if the imaging
is abnormal, does that actually fit into
a known malformation syndrome?
But again, we're still treating based on
the seizure type.
I'm preaching some job security here
because it's still based on us having
a good understanding
what types of seizures
are actually present.
But then if we do have a specific genetic
diagnosis, then we start to not only
look at the literature, but in these
specific instances that I have up here,
SCM1A, tuberous sclerosis and PCDH19,
we know that are specific
treatment strategies
to avoid, and some to lean more towards
that can be particularly effective
for those groups of patients.
Our hope is that someday, everyone who has
a diagnosis of epilepsy will actually have
a specific gene disorder
that we can actually
be a little bit more specific,
rather than just basing
it on the seizure type.
This is just a paper that was published
about seven years ago.
A lot has happened in seven years.
They're basically acknowledging
that genetic testing
is important and gonna become
increasingly important.
This is a beautiful graph that shows
the real availability of
next-generation sequencing.
The whole exome really
happened, it happened
where you can see the
blue bubble there, 2007.
It was about $100,000
to get it back in 2007.
Today, it's about, at some places,
you can get it for $5,000 for a trio,
so parents and a child.
You can see that in
the pre-next-generation
sequencing era, we were doing okay.
We had some pretty
important epilepsy genes,
all of which are associated
with various degrees
of intellectual disability.
Since the next-generation sequencing era,
you can see that there been this sort of
exponential rise in the
number of gene discoveries.
Not only has there been
an exponential rise
in the gene discoveries, but the amount
of research that's going on in each
of these specific genes is
also increasing dramatically.
Why does this matter?
I tell this story.
It's a story of Tracy Dixon-Salazar,
who is a friend and colleague of mine,
and who has a daughter
who had Lennox-Gastaut
of unknown cause.
She actually went to get her Ph.D
in developmental neuroscience.
This was right at the
time when whole exome
sequencing was just starting to become
a research tool.
She had a very typical presentation,
as I had on that graph of
Lennox-Gastaut syndrome,
with hundreds of seizures per month,
multiple medication trial, weekly use
of rescue medications.
Then she sequenced her
own daughter's exome.
They found an abnormality
in a calcium channel gene.
Generally, we don't reach toward
the cardiac calcium channel blockers
in the epilepsy space, but they put her
on a calcium channel blocker.
Lo and behold, she had a
95% reduction in seizures.
She had no need for rescue medications.
They were able to reduce
her other medications.
She had improved alertness and function.
Tracy tells her 20 minute story
at different meetings to really try
and drive home the utility
of genetic testing.
She shows pictures of her daughter
pre- and post-seizures.
It's really remarkable.
We do have an amazing
opportunity, I think,
ahead of us.
Just to cover some other things
just with single slides 'cause I know
that it's been addressed
here at this conference.
Infantile spasms, as I showed you,
are a common seizure type in children
with Down syndrome.
Interestingly, and this is by no means
a one size fits all, but children
with Down syndrome who present with
infantile spasms tend to
respond more favorably
than non-Down syndrome patients.
We actually don't understand that.
Maybe there's something
about the X chromosome.
We don't really understand.
They can still evolve into Lennox-Gastaut.
They may have other seizure types,
as you saw that that young woman
who had the tonic seizures.
The hard part here is that the EEG
can be abnormal, even with
no history of seizures.
Again, my job security, you have to get
a good history of a seizure.
Don't inappropriately diagnose someone
with epilepsy just because they have
an abnormal EEG.
You have to have the history
together with the EEG
to make that diagnosis.
Then here's just one
video I wanna show you,
in terms of how detailed
phenotyping actually
can lead to a genetic diagnosis.
I want you to watch this little girl.
Whoops.
Watch this little girl.
Go back one more.
They're gonna do it for me up at the box.
There you go. Thank you.
Describe what you see.
She's sleeping.
There's a little bit of hypermotoric,
maybe she's just up and she's cranky.
She's developmentally very abnormal.
She has some kicking
movements of the legs.
It's playing a little bit slower than.
Now we see some stiffening.
There's extension of the arms and legs.
We have hypermotor slash agitation.
Now we have stiffening, so we have tonic.
I won't let this play the whole time,
but she's gonna go into,
she's gonna relax here
and then almost go into a little spasm.
She's no longer an infant, so these
are not infantile spasms.
They're now called epileptic spasms.
But if we actually look at
the hypermotor tonic spasms.
This is a sequence.
This was actually
published in the Journal of Neurology
by the Australian group
because they noticed
that this was a
specific seizure type
that actually happened
in mostly girls.
CDKL5 encephalopathy
is a genetic diagnosis
that happens mainly with girls.
But we've actually, when
we evaluate patients,
infant girls who have spasms, and you get
this sort of history, now you know
the questions to ask.
You can go back.
"Does she ever wake up and
look like she's scared,
"and then that goes into the spasm?"
That can almost be your cheapest
genetic testing right here.
You can almost predict, nothing is 100%,
obviously, but you can almost predict
that this could be the diagnosis.
Why is this important?
Right now, we don't necessarily have
any specific treatments that are tailored
to CDKL5 encephalopathy, but again,
there's great, usually
parent-formed support groups
that really go a long
way, in terms of providing
that social support and
funding the necessary
research that we need.
This is just a quick slide to also show
that there's been a huge expansion
in the amount of anti-epileptic drugs
that have been available since 2000.
Unfortunately, a lot of
them aren't significantly
more effective than
the ones that were back
in the good old phenobarb/phenytoin ages,
but thankfully, they are better tolerated.
We have equal efficacy, but patients
are actually truly living
with their epilepsy,
and not falling asleep.
The emerging treatments.
This is kind of the wrapping up here.
Despite all of those new drugs, and again,
despite all those new drugs, the number
of treatment-resistant
patients, which we define
as still having seizures
despite medication,
has not changed, which
is embarrassing, I think.
We still use drugs.
There's devices and
there's all these nice,
fancy cutting-edge
things that are going on,
but drugs are still the main
treatment modality.
But our hope is, again, I keep hitting
the genetic drum, is that if we can get
to a better diagnosis, more accurate
genetic diagnosis, will that actually
lead to better treatments?
Cannabidiol.
There's been many, many reports,
even of cannabis sativa,
being used for various medical disorders.
Cannabidiol is just one
of the many compounds
in the cannabis plant.
The two that are getting
the most attention
are really CBD, cannabidiol, and THC,
so tetrahydrocannabinol,
which is what gives
the psychoactive component from cannabis.
Really, this all happened
five or six years ago
when many parents were frustrated with the
lack of effective treatments
for their children
with various epilepsy diagnoses,
but most specifically
with Dravet syndrome.
This one little girl named Charlotte Figi,
her parents, when they
were living in Colorado,
and Colorado's one of the first states
to have medical marijuana available,
tried her on a oil that
had a high concentration
of cannabidiol, and a
low concentration of THC.
Lo and behold, she actually
had a dramatic reduction
and had prolonged periods
of seizure freedom.
Sanjay Gupta got involved,
a lotta stuff happened.
There was a company that
actually, for decades,
had already been, had a pure form
of cannabidiol that was
plant extracted available.
They contacted a bunch of centers.
We were a center that
were involved with this,
where we basically did
an expanded access IND,
under compassionate use protocol.
We treated 214 patients with
treatment-resistant epilepsy.
This was not placebo controlled, so they
were just given cannabidiol.
They had a four-week
baseline seizure count,
followed by 12 weeks of treatment.
Everything was kept by seizure diary.
The median reduction in seizures
was about 35%.
It works.
There were some patients
that were seizure free.
A subsequent placebo controlled trial
that was done in Dravet syndrome
has been completed.
The median reduction in seizures
was 39%, compared to placebo of 13%.
So similar, but again,
we have to factor in
that placebo number.
That data is not published yet.
It's just a press release
data from the company.
This does work, but it's by no means,
it's another tool in our
toolbox, as we'll explain
to families, and it is by no means
the cure-all for many patients.
Wrapping up, where are we today in 2017?
To bring this to full closure, in terms
of the power of genetics.
I have some extremely
bright people that work
at UCSF that are taking these
known genetic epilepsies.
Scott Baraban at UCSF
has about 80 different
genetic mutations that
have been discovered
in forms of different pediatric epilepsy.
Using this new gene editing technology
called CRISPR, he's able to insert
the specific genetic
mutation into a zebrafish.
Why a zebrafish?
Turns out zebrafish can actually,
you can turn around large populations
of zebrafish, as compared to mice,
or even fruit flies.
Then you can literally take the zebrafish.
Many of them do have seizures.
I won't go into how they
see this fish seizing,
(laughter) but it's very interesting.
It's very, very interesting.
There's cameras.
Then they literally will
take different medications
and put them in the water.
Then the fish are
ingesting the medication.
They can do toxicity studies.
They can do different concentrations
of the medication.
They see which of these compounds actually
reduce seizures.
He does this in a blinded way.
This really, I think, is a whole other era
for drug repurposing.
You have drugs that are already out there
and FDA approved, that we already have
the toxicity data, but
we just never thought
to try them in patients with epilepsy.
So in a blinded fashion,
he takes these compounds,
he puts 'em in the
water, he sees which ones
actually cause a reduction in seizure.
Then you unveil the bottle and see
what drug it is, and then start to look
into how that drug works
and better understand
the mechanism of action.
I really think that this is going
to be a very, very important technology
to give us some better treatments.
Last slide, so take home points.
Hopefully you will not just say
generalized tonic-clonic seizure.
Epilepsy has many different faces,
and all seizures can look
very, very different.
I've put my foot in my
mouth so many times.
I say, "Oh, that can't be a seizure."
If it's stereotyped and it's recurrent,
don't blow it off.
Have it evaluated further.
We know that patients with
developmental disabilities
are particularly
challenging, due to the many
different underlying etiologies.
Again, this accurate classification
of seizures is critical so that we can,
ideally, arrive at some gene discoveries
with some more targeted-based treatments.
Thank you.
- [Woman] Thank you.
(applause)